foreign
two weeks ago now I was in Portland for
a few days and hanging in coffee shops
and watching people and um and also
walking walking around various
neighborhoods watching people
and I had the thought as I did
multiple times when we lived in Portland
uh and you know less so now that we're
on an island without as many without as
much Commerce without as many
opportunity to sort of run into into
people and to do people watching without
it being really obvious that you're
being watched
um
I had the thought
dogs may be the ones to save us dogs May
save
the world uh insofar as
they break down the borders between
people and it's easier if both strangers
to one another have dogs because the
dogs don't care and uh you know
increasingly there are people who are
like oh no no don't you know well my dog
doesn't get along with it I'm like okay
well you know I wish she had taught your
dog to be a dog then and like I know
that some dogs really can't can't do
this thing with other dogs but that's
not very dog-ish of them but in general
dogs are curious about other dogs dogs
are also curious about other people but
people tend to be interested in dogs and
dogs are definitely interested in dogs
and whereas people especially in cities
are quite happy to walk by each other
and either pretend the other person
doesn't exist or often just sort of
stare at them or you know make a scowl
or something how dare you smile at me
once the dog has uh once they've gone up
to each other and investigate each other
either nose to nose or nose to butt or
you know all the various configurations
by which dogs greet each other the
people especially if the dogs are
leashed and are therefore pulled into
Closer Closer proximity
have a much harder time being Grim with
one another
they just have a much much more
difficult time
and
this does this is true regardless of you
know whether or not you're one of those
rare people who actually doesn't like
dogs
um and I'm not saying like oh cat people
like
I sort of think of myself as a cat
person more than a dog person but come
on dogs right like it's dogs the one
thing we can all agree on yeah something
with you we've got as you you have
pointed out uh what something like and
you know there's a there's a lot of
different ways in and there's some
competing uh hypotheses out there yet
but something like well many tens of
thousands of years of co-evolution with
dogs and uh really what that means is
that we have co-evolved with them
they have you know we oh yeah we
domesticated dogs dogs are you know our
longest uh domesticate yeah but you know
we have co-evolved with dogs and uh they
are showing us
they're reminding us if we let them as
we watch the ways that dogs interact
with each other on the street and with
with with the owners uh how to be our
best selves and if we can if we can
listen to them and watch them and
interact a little bit more like they do
we might find a way out a little bit
more quickly yeah dogs I I love this
point of yours and I I quite agree with
it I've seen the online version of this
where people put aside their differences
uh to remark on yeah very often dogs and
their interesting Behavior I do think
it's interesting uh you know we all know
examples of dogs
you know who picked up their owner's
racism or whatever yeah right right that
used to happen much more I believe
because I think racism went out of
fashion and you know it's back hopefully
the dogs will not pick it up this time
but
um but there is something dogs are
something like three times as long under
our our uh under our mutualism as our
next closest domesticate because their
domestication had nothing to do with
farming whereas everything else is post
farming dogs are older in the human
lineage than rice
by far Yeah by far yeah about three
times as you say but the there is
something you know you
no owner controls what their dog thinks
of some other dog dogs have their own
thoughts so there is bragged into an
interaction in which the nature of the
human beings and even the other dog is
you know that is beyond yours to say
anything about and
um you know I love the idea that dogs
might remind us of our more ancient
selves remind us how much is at stake
and how lucky we are to even be here you
know what did the last 30 000 years look
like that we should arrive at this
moment where we do have uh enough
control over the natural world that we
can you know dedicate ourselves to
abstractions and the creation of Art and
beauty and all of these things because
more or less we have the basics taken
care of and why we would toy with
wrecking that right why we wouldn't be
obsessed with preserving what we've
accomplished so that we can actually
move forward rather than have it all
detonate out from under us
um you know a dog is a pretty good
reminder of that if you if you tune into
it correctly yeah very much so
[Music]